hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so for those who are watching my video
for the first time let me quickly
introduce myself
i used to work as a professional trader
i have just resigned guys
for you to be here to make everyday
updates
on gamestop amc or anything you want me
to make an update on
i'm also gonna be to be able to do live
trading with you
soon so you're gonna see how i actually
do my trades
on the live market i'm also gonna start
to do more training for myself because i
need you know to make some money as well
as i have no more jobs for now
so i'm gonna show you guys everything
i'm probably gonna take some positions
on my favorite stocks as well which i
was not allowed to do so this is a new
start for me
this is a new adventure that i'm
starting right now with you guys and
today i want to make a
huge update on amc let's get into it
so amc what do we have we have a lot of
things today
so as usual i'm gonna go step by step
let me first
remind you what i told you guys in my
previous video so in the previous video
there was
not anything like this we were like this
in my previous video i have different
scenarios
i had one scenario like this all right
like we go right away to the fifth wave
or another scenario that was actually
making a correction a bit longer
so i was going to 35 you know because i
was telling you we
might have a flat correction but here
like right now we're having more
information
and once again you know corrective
patterns it can be a zigzag
a flat or triangle i get all this
information from here guys i'm going to
bring you through this this is the idiot
wave course that i
you know this is the online book you
just type idiot wave theory on
google and you can find this right away
in the first links
so i read this book i did a summary of
it on the link in the description of
this video so just click on it guys
you're gonna
be really amazed i try to make it easy
to understand
and i think it's very good information
for you even if you're new to the theory
you're gonna understand you know the
psychological mechanisms that are behind
which waves
why the wave counting is actually
working in any type of market
where you have enough liquidity and how
to basically
use this information to set up your
trades so i'm also building
a comprehensive course guys that is
going to be amazing where i basically
give you step by step all the methods
that i like to use i'm going to explain
exactly how to do it guys it's going to
be for beginners for advanced traders as
well
i'm going to put everything i'm going to
put my heart in building this course
so that says this is as well the reason
why i resigned i want to you know share
the knowledge that i have
i've been using these methods for many
years and some of them they're working
very
very well for me so i want to show you
guys exactly
how i do this so once again let me
remind you here
what is happening guys so since this
breakout here you guys are with me for
those who are watching my videos
you know that i'm calling this levels
for a long time we went to 35
like i expected long time ago and this
third wave was actually
even higher than this so i did an update
after we corrected to 26
and i told you guys that this impulse is
so strong
that we're probably going to go to 75
right away before correcting and this is
what
happened so let me just remind you guys
what techniques i use here so i measured
the third wave
and i applied it to the bottom of my
false wave
here and this is how i find the 75 level
all right
so here so depending exactly you know
you should do it on the hourly of four
hours time frame it's an area between 65
and 75 so
right now it's giving me 72 but once
again guys fibs are not trend lines all
right it gives you approximative levels
it gives you areas
where you usually have some resistance
or support
reactions and here it's the reason why
i choose 72 in this example is because
it's the 1.618 guys the golden number
you can find this number everywhere guys
in finance and if you know how to use
this ratio
you're gonna see that it's both
interesting to use it to enter some
trades by using field retracements
but it's also very very good to use to
find targets
especially in this kind of markets that
just go higher and higher so here
once again i'm going to go back to it
very soon but first let me show you how
i find
my new target i measured the third wave
i applied to the bottom of the four
swipes so if one of the bottom is here
and it gives me 137 so this is my level
i think we're gonna go there in the
fifth wave we're having a false wave but
what is it guys
you need to ask yourself what is the
correction you're having because once
you know what
what type of correction you have you
know when it's gonna be finished
so here guys look just connect the highs
and the lows and you can see that here
guys
we're having a nice triangle so when you
spot a triangle you need to wonder
like which position it is happening and
it's here in the false wave then you go
to the idiot wave
course or you click on the link in the
description of this video and it's going
to be the same thing
so here you have the explanation of what
are triangles less than eight
triangles and what is very interesting
that i wanted to show you guys
is this although upon extremely rare
occasions in the second wave in an
impulse appears to take the form of a
triangle
triangles nearly always occur in
positions
prior to the final actionary wave in the
pattern of one
larger degree it asked as wave 4
in an impulse wave b in an abc or the
final wave x in a double or triple
zigzag or combinations
so we are here in this situation as wave
four in an impulse all right so this is
what we're having we're having here
one two three four this is my triangle
so i know it's a force i know it's a
triangle i know there's going to be a
fifth wave
and this is how technical analysis is
working
so once again i might be wrong here
every time you know i might be wrong
but i'm very confident in this scenario
now
we can go back on the first time frame
and here you can see as well guys that
you know you need to find some support
and resistance levels so
this triangle can also become suddenly
like this it's still gonna be a triangle
so this is the reason why i told you at
the beginning
we might go back to 35 but maybe not
maybe not look here we're having this
on the first time frame we're having the
50 moving average that is acting as
support so it has not been touched maybe
it's going to be touched or maybe not
so if you're wondering what is the next
move to make if
i was training this market which i'm not
for now but i'm gonna be very soon guys
i'm gonna be allowed to do it uh but i i
need some some time just to you know
properly finish my contract so for now
i'm not allowed to trade
amc but if i was i would be a buyer of
course around the 35 37 area
i would be buying around the 40 area
because i have here the
50 per moving average coming and if it's
not coming to me then it's fine
because you know what is gonna happen
after the triangle guys
it's always the same thing so here it's
an example all right of a triangle but
you can see
breakout retest we go higher 90
of the time so it's gonna look like this
here so i don't know
let's count the number of waves we have
in here let's count usually
triangles have five waves so this is
giving me another information about when
this correction is going to finish all
right
zigzag and flat have both three waves
triangles
have five waves guys so one
two three four
five all right so let me make it like a
bit theoretically
perfect so this is not the triangle i'm
having my triangle
is here guys all right
so here we might already be done guys we
might already be done
maybe this is a one we're gonna have a
two three four five all right
so this is one scenario all right so as
usual guys now i'm giving you my
scenarios
actually the one is gonna go here the
two is gonna go here right so this is
one scenario
let's call it my preferred scenario i
think you know it's very likely it
happens like this
another scenario that you might have is
this one the triangle
breaks here we do usually they have five
waves but look here we have a nine
wave triangle it can happen guys you
just have one wave that is extended
inside
this five waves so maybe we're gonna
have a b
you know maybe this is just a c and then
we're gonna have d and e
this is possible as well so you know
it's not because we go lower here
and go to 35 that is bad news it's good
news guys right if 35 breaks
then it's a bit bad news but once again
there is an alternative scenario that
goes here
right it's possible as well and then we
could do
you know a kind of zigzag flat
you know this is on the table as well so
i don't know exactly what is happening
for now
but i know that all this area is a
buying area all right so i wouldn't buy
here definitely not and here you can see
we are on the hourly time frame we broke
the 20 period moving average that was
supporting the price here
we broke it we retested it once rejected
second time
so here i'm definitely not a buyer but
if the price action
goes like here brexit on the first time
frame
then retest then i'm gonna feel very
good
then it means that this scenario is
playing out let me show you guys again
the scenario
all right this is my preferred scenario
guys
and for those who are watching my videos
for some time you know that my preferred
scenario
is usually the good one so i think we're
gonna do something like this but once
again i have
one two or three alternative scenarios
that go back
as low as 25 you know this is the most
bearish scenario i have
once again because you know force wave
they like to retrace either to the top
of the third wave
so 35 or the bottom of the force wave
three or four
so in both cases guys we are bullish so
all my scenarios for now lead to 135
everything can happen so you just need
to stay you know focus
and aware that anything can happen and
right now guys i want to go with you
through
the financial data all right guys so let
me start with
the most interesting data that you guys
probably having already but
uh you know i'm sorry i didn't update
you guys uh more often this week
as i told you i was busy with the
handover of my resignation
but here i was waiting for the 28th of
may data that was released i think three
or four days ago
and you can see guys the short interest
you know the short interest
is up guys the total short share
is 102 million up from 95 million
two weeks before so it's very
interesting
to see that the shots are not covering
despite this very high levels actually
you want to know what is happening
shorts are covering and they are
creating this uh strong moves up but
there are new
short investors that are coming in the
game that are like hey
amc is at 50 it's too high let's sell
this right
go sell it you're gonna see you know
it's people who
unfortunately don't know enough about
technical analysis i think
so we're gonna find out what is gonna
happen but they're gonna be
some more shots coming if we go to this
higher levels
and once this shorts are large enough
we can have a short squeeze so the short
interest is at 21
so it's increasing now let me show you
what we're having on the option market
guys
so i keep here all the information that
i get on yahoo finance
of all the maturities all the listed
strikes so i go to the 145
strike and i go to the gen 23 maturity
right i take all of them
i compute the delta myself using black
trolls formula that is here guys
for those who are interesting to do it
yourself i
put the formula here so it's n of d1 d1
is equal to logarithm of
s divided by k s is the spot case the
strike plus
volatility to the square times t so
volatility must be near here
divided by volatility times square root
of time in
year all right so then you are able to
get your delta that is the probability
we finish in the money once again this
is why this data is very interesting to
look at because it means for example if
i take the
145 strike for the due maturity
all right the delta is only four percent
guys the delta is only four percent
but i think that the priority you finish
there is higher
you can see that the number of 145 call
options is growing guys go check my
previous video it was around here
now we are here guys we are almost we
were at 3 million shares
we are now at 8 million shares guys so
this is good this is what is creating
this bullish momentum on the upside so i
want to see those options growing
and they are this is good this is
telling me that the gamma squeeze can
happen again
we having right now a total synthetic
short exposure of 19
on the option market compared to
gamestop for example where we're only at
10
it's much higher because those options
most of them they are in the money
we just went through all the big strikes
we went through the 40 strikes
this is why we had this very strong
moves up and once again we having the
expiry guys when is it
18th of june and look the number of
options we have in here guys we having
on the june maturity 700 000 options
guys
so for example the on the 8 million
shares we're having on the 145 strike
most of it comes to the june maturity
so this is extremely bullish guys i like
to see this kind
of bullish momentum here and and the
volatility yeah let's have a look at the
volatility guys
so i keep the big strikes volatility so
here is the 40 strike
here is the 70 strike and here is 145
strike guys and we're having
volatilities for the due maturity 338
guys so very very big volatility because
market makers
need protection for this event to if
this
even happens and let's check the delta
the delta after for example september
maturity guys for 145 strike
look guys the delta is 55 percent 55
chance amc trades above 145 in uh
september guys
so guys this is very bullish everybody
is bullish here
everybody gets in the mc trade we're
gonna see some
more moves up we are finishing this five
waves development after the triangle
finishes so this is what you guys
can use as a signal to enter a trade for
example to
trade this fifth wave so i gave you here
guys i think very
interesting information so i hope you
enjoyed it and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys